so the sports writer came in and he said
listen man i haven't seen a performance
like that ever in my life
he says i want to give you a nickname
irvin we got to call you something
somebody's called big e somebody's
called dr j how about magic you know
you're like yeah right
you know you you start laughing like
yeah okay
my boy's not gonna call me magic you
know
and within two months everybody in
michigan knew who magic was
and i had heard about this kid
you know urban magic johnson i was like
who's this dude every magic johnson
never saw him but just kept hearing how
great he was as a basketball player
[Music]
have you seen this kid
in lansing
this 15 year old black kid from the
midwest
they call him magic have you seen him
irvin johnson you're a very sought after
player you shoot well you pass well you
dribble score assist we're trying to
figure out what you do best do you know
we can't figure it out
when the newspapers really started
getting involved and then start getting
the big headlines
you know that's when he basically became
the pied piper whatever game he was
playing everybody wanted to go see it
[Music]
you could not find a seat any place you
just could not find a seat
you